je hais
en septembre 2010 les notes queen est un
spectacle en france et ce soir là
alexandre appelé chez jan o a la chance
de discuter avec lui on a discuté en
profondeur surtout des effets de billes
oui en tout sept ce contexte où il ya
écrit alléluia jeu
la montréalaise n'a jamais revu le poète
elle était loin de se douter que cinq
mois après sa mort on lui demanderait de
travailler sur son livre posthume
je voulais être à la hauteur jeu surtout
être fidèle à le nude les notes cohen a
travaillé sur son recueil de textes
jusqu'à sa mort
le curateur de l'héritage à approcher
cette docteur en théologie
passionné de l'oeuvre du poète pourrait
viser les transcriptions en avril 2007
est mort on me le cartable blanc ce
qu'on appelle le wild bunch et prendre
le relais du jour couture ce cartable
comprenez 63 poèmes qui des paroles de
chansons et des extraits de carnets de
notes rédigées depuis l'adolescence tous
minutieusement choisis par cohen
alexandre appelé chez yano en réviser
chaque texte est choisi des dessins pour
les accompagner un travail de moine
je rentrais dans les archives puis
essayer de voir que ce qui était écrit
une leur réalisme houle dont il faut
remettre c'est de revoir jusqu'à la
virgule de revoir parce que en poésie
tout compte
pourtant le nouveau livre intitulé de
flame n'est qu'une infime partie de
l'oeuvre inédite de leonard cohen
le livre représente entre 5 à 10 % des
unités de seulement seulement parce
qu'on on continue de découvrir
et puis alors des richesses la toux ayew
study of heaven
des richesses qui seront sans doute
dévoilés au grand jour
mais pour le moment le dernier grand
projet de leonard cohen est traduit en
vingt langues
ici julie jocelyne boudreault fin du
canada montréal sous le